merci madame la Présidente
chers collègues au nom du groupe Riou je
souhaite demander selon l'article 158 du
règlement un vote sur un ajout alors du
jour en cette ouverture de session notre
groupe souhaiterait proposer l'ajout
d'une déclaration du Conseil et de la
Commission sur l'aide au plus démunis
dans le contexte d'une précarité
croissante en Europe sans résolution le
débat serait ajouté mercredi après-midi
comme cinquième point en conséquence la
session serait prolongée d'une heure
pourquoi cette demande chers collègues
dans plusieurs États membres la
situation devient allamment alarmante
pour de nombreuses associations d'aide
au plus démunis avec l'inflation des
prix alimentaires les demandes d'aide
explosent et par ailleurs les coûts de
fonctionnement augmentent avec des coûts
croissants pour l'énergie notamment et
enfin les dons diminuent malheureusement
une suffisent plus tous les indicateurs
sont au rouge les chiffres sont
alarmants et les associations qui four
nissent une aide alimentaire accueille
des bénéficiaires qu'elle ne voyait pas
auparavant des personnes âgées des
familles monoparentales des étudiants
des chômeurs des réfugiés Ukrainiens le
problème était que certaines demandes ne
peuvent plus ou ne pourrons plus être
honorés au nom de Rio Europe je pense
que cette question mérite débat et
qu'elle requiert une déclaration de la
Commission et du Conseil merci Madame br